let's see if we can understand a thing
or two about futures curves and i've
drawn two futures curves here and really
all they show is the different the
different settlement prices for the
different delivery dates of futures so
let's say that this orange curve is one
of them what this says is if today if
for delivery today we wanted to buy or
sell an apple the market rate is 10
cents a pound so this isn't the futures
contract at all this is actually called
the spot price it's essentially the
market price for that commodity or that
security today we're just using the
example of apple so this tells us at
time zero you can buy or sell an apple
based on the current market for 10 cents
now when we move to one the way i've
labeled this axis this says one month
one month from now this is not saying
that the market price is going to go up
one month from now this is saying that
today if you were to go into the futures
market and say i want to sell or i want
to buy apples one month from now what
type of a settlement price can i get on
my futures contract and based on this
futures curve it looks like we could do
about 12 cents i want to let me i just
want to re i'm going to repeat what i
just said this is not saying that
a month from now that the market price
that the spot price is going to move up
only this time zero is the spot price
what this is saying is right now the
market is saying if you want to enter
into a futures contract for delivery a
month from now that delivery price will
be 10 12 cents if you want to del
deliver two months from now that
delivery price might be around 15 cents
if you want to deliver eight months from
now that delivery price might be
something like 20 cents if you wanted to
show movement let's say all of a sudden
people just get more bullish on apples
or there's some new diet that tells
everyone that apples help you lose
weight what you would probably see is
this entire curve would shift up so
regardless of delivery date you would
probably see this entire curve shift up
because people would want apples across
the entire across the entire futures
curve and this one that we're
highlighting right now i've drawn two
futures curves i've drawn an upward
sloping orange one and i've also drawn a
downward sloping blue one and i'll focus
on that one in the next video but this
upward sloping is kind of a normal curve
and it's actually called that it's a
normal curve because this is what you
actually expect for most types of
commodities you can imagine why if this
if if you if this wasn't upward sloping
there would actually be no reason for
you to hold on to something especially
if this was downward sloping you'd be
like wow if for future delivery dates
i'm getting lower and lower prices why
don't i just sell now and that would
actually create downward pressure on the
current spot price and you could of
course make the arbitrage arguments i
made in previous videos why you
shouldn't in a theoretical setting see a
downward sloping futures curve what
we're going to talk a little bit about
in the next video is maybe why you would
see a downward sloping futures curve
where the delivery price for for
delivery further out than the spot price
or for further out months than nearby
months is actually lower and just to
give you a little terminology this type
of curve right here is called an
inverted curve and i'll talk in the next
video on why you might see one of those